لتعلن قطر انتصارها. لاعبو
المنتخب الايراني الاحد عشر
يمتنع عن اداء النشيد الوطني
خلال عزفه قبيل مواجهته مع
بجديد والعراق في محله يعاني
الويلات. حيث وجه الحرس الثوري
بالهستيرية على قواعد الفصائل
الكردية التي تقع في شمال سوريا
طائرات تتبع الحوثيين احداها
اصابت منصة النفط بميناء الضبة
الثوري ويقول على العراق اخراج
المجموعات المعادية لنا
في حضرموت وسببت اضرارا. اوروبا
تتابع احداث محطة زبروجيا كما
الامريكية في اربيل جراء القصف
الايراني ويخرج نائب قائد الحرس
يدينها او يضغط عليها بشكل دائم.
فيا لا وفاء هؤلاء الحلفاء الذين
والعراق. العراق تحت القصف.
حكومة العراق الجديدة لم تأت
لا بعضهم بعضا. لتعود ليندا
توماس قائلة سنقدم فرصة لمجلس
بينار الحدودي مع سوريا بولاية
كيليز جنوبي البلاد. لتدعو
يتجاوز الحدود. بعد تأشيرة عبور
من الولايات المتحدة ها هو
والسبب بسيط. ليأتي الرد من
المندوب الصيني بمجلس الامن
المرة العاشرة التي نبقيها بدون
رد فعل ملموس على بيونج يانج
اجرتها كوريا الشمالية مؤخرا
لتخرج مندوبة الولايات المتحدة
ستعود للحطب بعد ذلك. ومن ازمة
اوروبا الى حلول واشنطن
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها ايران.
وزارة الدفاع اليمنية اعتراض
للمشترين في الفورية واسعار
السوق الفورية تعادل ثلاثة اضعاف
وثلاثين لالتزامها بهدف التحول
للطاقة البديلة. لكن يبدو انها
باربعة ملايين طن سنويا. المشكلة
تبقى في اوروبا فكل الغاز المسال
بعرقلة رد مجلس الامن الدولي على
تجارب اطلاق الصواريخ التي
بقوله ان على المجلس لعب دور
بناء تجاه كوريا الشمالية والا
العقود الطويلة. اوروبا رفضت
الالتزام بعقود غاز بعد الفين
قبل الفين وستة وعشرين مباع سلفا
بعقود طويلة ما يترك كميات قليلة
خلفها وهو الامر الذي تعلمه
واشنطن التي اتهمت روسيا والصين
تتابع كأس العالم لكن الاوروبيين
هنا يضعون ايديهم على قلوبهم.
والمانيا وبلجيكا وهولندا
والدنمارك وويلز وسويسرا من
سيادتكم على النفاذ? الاحداث
والتطورات. الفيفا يمنع انجلترا
ارتداء شارة المثليين في كأس
العالم قطر الفين واثنين وعشرين
انجلترا ضمن مونديال قطر الفين
واثنين وعشرين تضامنا مع
ترى? خلال ذلك اعلنت وزارة
الداخلية التركية اصابة ثمانية
المانيا تركيا الى رد متناسب
يتوافق مع القانون الدولي
لفرنسا في افريقيا لخدمة طموحها
المتوحش في دول افريقية مضطربة
السبب لكن لابد وانكم علمتم
لماذا? هنا ازمة جديدة تلوح في
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
روسيا بتغذية دعاية مناهضة
الافق بين روسيا وفرنسا يا سادة
وحرب موسكو قد تنتقل الى باريس.
ذلك انتهاكا للسيادة وماذا بعد
يا حكومات العراق? هل اوشك رصيد
من نائب رئيس البرلمان العراقي
بادانة القصف الايراني معتبرا
والمدعومة من واشنطن وتل ابيب من
اراضيه. بينما الرد العراقي جاء
الكردي في العراق لتدوي صافرات
الانذار في مقر السفارة
اقتصاده. بينما قال وزير دفاع
لتوانيا. ان بلاده قررت عدم
الغاز المسال والذي فازت به
الصين وتركت اوروبا في ورطتها
الايراني ضربات بالصواريخ
والمسيرات ضد مقار لحزب العمال
جمهورية مصرحة ان الاعمال
القتالية في اوكرانيا هي فقط جزء
وتنصحها بضبط النفس ذلك بعد
تنفيذ تركيا عدة ضربات جوية وصفت
من عناصر الامن اثر هجوم براجمات
صواريخ استهدف منطقة معبر انجو
كم يلتزم مدرجات المشجعين هذه
المرة ليضحك. الغضب التركي
اردوغان يلوح عملية برية في
سوريا. فهل تسرع هذا العثماني يا
الامن لمحاسبة كوريا الشمالية
على اعمالها المزعزعة للاستقرار.
تسليم الجانب الاوكراني مدافع
هاوزر ذاتية الدفع ولم يفصح عن
زج الدول الاخرى في الحرب بدلا
عنكم يا هؤلاء حلفاء كوريا
لا تسعى الى المواجهة والصراع مع
الصين ولكنها ترحب بالمنافسة هي
الامريكي كاميل هاريس وتقول انها
ابلغت الرئيس الصيني ان واشنطن
بمنطقة استراتيجية مهمة. لكن هل
يجعل الفلبينيون انفسهم درعا
مع الفلبين لردع اي صيني على
تايوان والرد عليه فالفلبين تحظى
السليمة ضد الغرب. الصينيون عن
اطول عقد في التاريخ لتصدير
وستحققها لكن تغيير سلطة كييف
ليس هدفا للعملية العسكرية
عن المعارك عند ارتفاع البرودة
خلال اشهر الشتاء. ليخرج رئيس
النفط نعود الى الحرب الاوكرانية
حيث قال المتحدث باسم الكريملين
انسانية في المدينتين بسبب
البنية التحتية المدمرة للكهرباء
بينما تستعد موسكو وقواتها من
جانب وكييف وقواتها من جانب اخر
للامريكان امام بكين في حال غزت
الصين تايوان لتخرج نائبة الرئيس
لدى المتحدة ليندا توماس
جرينفيلد وتقول بحسرة هذه هي
الشمالية. كوريا الشمالية لن
تمشي وحيدا ما بكين وموسكو تقفان
الاستراتيجية. حيث تسعى الولايات
المتحدة لتعزيز التعاون الدفاعي
وعشرين. ليتسم الحظ للروس مجددا
بعد ان خرج نائب رئيس الوزراء
ديمتري بسكوف ان روسيا تريد
تحقيق اهدافها في اوكرانيا
يتلقون الضربات تلو الضربات.
وبكين تضحك ملوحة بمواقفها
من الولايات المتحدة لتدمير
الاتحاد الاوروبي والسيطرة على
الروسية الجارية الان في
اوكرانيا لتخرج السيناتور عن
تشحن نفطها ومنتجاتها النفطية
وفقا لسقف السعر ومن مهاترات
منطقة دونيتسك الشرقية. ومن خطة
الانسحاب الى تكتيك الشتاء
حائرة حيث وقعت قطر عقدا مع بكين
لسبعة وعشرين عاما لتزودها
لتعاود نفوذها وتأثيرها. الصين
تضع اوروبا في ورطة. خصوم الصين
النفط. مضيفا ان موسكو ستبقى
موردا موثوقا للطاقة لكنها لن
الروسي قائلا قد نلجأ لتخفيض
الانتاج في حال تم فرض سقف لسعر
الحالي بواقع مليوني برميل يوميا
سيستمر حتى نهاية الفين وثلاثة
اللجنة العسكرية في الناتو مصرحا
ان الحلف يعاني من نقص في البنية
على قدم وساق لمعارك الشتاء لكن
تقارير غربية تتوقع توقف الطرفين
السعودي ينفي وبشكل قاطع مناقشة
الرياض مع منتجي اوبك زيادة
على طول الحدود اللتوانية
الفولاندية وذلك بحسب رويترز.
التحتية على الجبهة الشرقية وفي
عدة دول وان الحلف لارسال قوات
هنا ننتقل الى الحرب النفطية.
وبعد ان تحدثت ويليستريت جورنال
الانتاج بمقدار خمسمائة الف
برميل يوميا وان خفض الانتاج
عن نية السعودية زيادة انتاج
اوبك بلس ها هو وزير الطاقة
اجلاء لسكان خرسون وميكرويف.
وتتخوف سلطات كييف من حدوث ازمات
والبرد واستعداد لشتاء قارس.
سلطات كييف تعتزم القيام بعمليات
فهل
كثيفة والنية الحقيقية لانسحاب
القوات كانت اعادة نشر الجنود في
استراتيجية روسية للسيطرة على
دومبس باكملها بهجمات صاروخية
جورنال فبعد الانسحاب من خرسون
كشفت الصحيفة تفاصيل خطة
استعادتها. وفي شبه جزيرة القرم
هناك تعزز روسيا تحصينات قواتها
فهل غيرت موسكو استراتيجيتها من
الهجوم الى الدفاع ام ان هناك
مدينة روسية لطالما فكر وتحدث
سكانها باللغة الروسية وستتم
الاحتياطيين. التهديدات ايضا
لمتر ميدفيديف يرد على التهديدات
الخارج الامريكية روسيا قامت
بعمليات اعدام جماعية في
حيث تقوم بحفر الخنادق لاميال
خلف الخطوط الامامية استعدادا
باليستية لروسيا. ليصرح مستشار
رئيس مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني ان
روسيا لا تريد مفاوضات سلام بل
مهلة عملياتية بينما تدرب
زيلينسكي ليحث الناتو على ضمان
حماية المفاعلات النووية
المحطة. فمن الذي يريد تفجير
المحطة يا ترى? هنا يخرج
الاوكرانية باستعادة شبه جزيرة
القرم بقوله ان كييف وببساطة
اوكرانيا. وهنا هيئة الاذاعة
الاسرائيلية تقول ان هناك
زبروج النووية وان ذلك يعرض
العالم باسره للخطر في الدفاع
فيما اتهمت وكالة الطاقة النووية
الاوكرانية روسيا بقصف محطة
متبادلة بين الطرفين ليعلنها
مدير عام الوكالة الدولية للطاقة
الذرية قصف محطة للطاقة النووية
غير مقبول ويجب ان يتوقف فورا.
الروسية توجه الاتهام للقوات
الاوكرانية بشن قصف مدفعي على
انسحابا روسيا جديدا في المقاطعة
الاربع ليأتي الرد من بول ستريت
عسكرية كبرى قد تشنها القوات
الاوكرانية في الايام المقبلة.
نيويورك. فلماذا يا ترى? روسيا
تتحضر للكارثة. الجنوب الاوكراني
يعلن معارضته لحكومة طهران من
وسط كأس العالم قطر تنتصر على
دول الغرب والفيفا يؤيد قراراتها
وبايدن يعلن حالة الطوارئ في
زبروجيا بالمقامرة النووية من
روسيا. حرب الاتهامات تتواصل هنا
معلومات استخباراتية تشير الى ان
ايران على وشك تسليم صواريخ
ورطة. واردوغان يستعد لعملية
برية في سوريا المانيا ترد.
الاوكرانية من اي عبث روسي بينما
يصف الاتحاد الاوروبي قصف محطة
العراق يتعرض لضربات ايرانية
مجددا بينما المنتخب الايراني
على صفيح ساخن النووي لا يزال
يلوح في الافق مع اتهامات
يجري وحرب من نوع اخر بين ماكرون
وبوتين وموسكو تهدد باسترجاع
حرب المحطة النووية تشتعل يستنجد
بالناتو وبعد اجلاء روس السكان
كييف فيما الصين توجه ضربة قوية
لاوروبا وتجعل الاوروبيين في
من خرسون ها هي اوكرانيا تتبعها
باخلاء المنطقة ايضا. فما الذي